سيدريك لايتون هو محلل عسكري في سي إن إن وعقيد متقاعد
بالقوات الجوية الأمريكية ، ومن
الجيد أن أراك F-16s
على رأس قائمة التسوق للرئيس
زيلينسكي لماذا من المهم أن
تتلقى أوكرانيا هذه الطائرات إذا استطاعوا
وما الذي يميزهم عن غيرهم لماذا
كن مغيرًا للعبة ربما في هذا
الصراع ،
نعم أبولو ، F-16 هي
طائرة مثيرة للاهتمام حقًا كانت موجودة
منذ حوالي 49 عامًا ولدي 40+ من
تلك التي تعمل بالفعل وهي
مقاتلة متعددة الأدوار لذا يمكنها القيام بكل من
الجو-إلى  - العمليات القتالية الجوية وجو - أرض ،
لذا فإن ما يعنيه ذلك هو أنها
متعددة الاستخدامات حقًا ويمكن استخدامها بعدة
طرق مختلفة وهي أيضًا
طائرة اعتمادًا على كيفية
تكوينها ، فمن المحتمل أن تستخدم
قدرتها على التشويش الإلكتروني
لملاحقة بعض  الرادارات الروسية
النشطة في أوكرانيا وحول
المحيط الأوكراني ، لذا فهي
طائرة مهمة جدًا ، وربما تكون
أفضل طائرة من حيث جميع
القدرات المختلفة التي
قد يرغب بها الأوكرانيون ، وربما تكون
الطائرة الوحيدة التي تتمتع بكل هذه
القدرات في واحدة  طَرد